Zack Efron got Mega jacked for Baywatch
but he still managed to level up his
visique for the upcoming wrestling
biopic the iron claw here's how for more
than half a century with members
spanning three generations the von Eric
family has become legendary in the
wrestling world leading to their
induction into the WWE Hall of Fame in
2009 on hand to receive this prestigious
honor was Kevin adinon AKA Kevin von
Eric the last surviving son the
fascinating and tragic story of Kevin
and the rest of the von Eric family is
the subject of the iron claw in which
the famous wrestler is portrayed by Zach
Efron to play the part Efron had to
transform his body in a massive effort
that may be on par with what he
underwent in preparation for Baywatch
which is very impressive however while
that experience had its upsides it also
had significant downsides that taught
him what worked and what didn't for this
movie in particular we' like we wanted
to achieve a look and that required a a
specific type of training the actor then
took that knowledge and used it to
accomplish the new goal of increasing
his bulk considerably with great results
let's take a look at the vital steps the
actor took to pull off his latest
formidable look Efron was in incredibly
great shape for his role in Baywatch but
to achieve those results the actor may
have pushed himself to a level exceeding
his co-stars at the time Efron was all
for putting the work in as told Men's
Journal there's this trigger that
happens after 2 or 3 weeks of dieting
and eating healthy food where your body
switches its primary energy source from
burning mainly carbohydrates to burning
fat the actor relished the process
because it would make him crave Foods he
should be eating like sweet potatoes
beets and kale instead of the junk that
would just make his goals harder to
accomplish on the other hand the extreme
steps it took to maintain the chiseled
abs of a Greek god were eventually not
worth it a few years after the film was
released Efron admitted to Men's Health
I started to develop insomnia and I fell
into a pretty bad depression for a long
time something about that experience
burned me out I had a really hard time
reentering despite the dark moments
Efron learned a lot from that experience
and now fully understands the toll it
takes to have almost no body fat the
more you learn the more your workouts
evolve and
change by far the worst part of Efron's
bayw watch experience was the need to
use pills called diuretics which are
usually intended as a treatment for high
blood pressure according to the Mayo
Clinic diuretics help remove both sodium
and water from your body an effect that
is very useful when trying to cut as
much weight as possible yet this ended
up doing more harm than good and was
determined as the main reason for
Efron's descent into depression during
filming as he told Men's Health
ultimately they chocked it up to taking
way too many diuretics for way too long
and it messed something up
fortunately to play Kevin von Eric in
the iron claw none of that was needed
and the actor has Preferred it that way
going forward he added that Baywatch
look I don't know if that's really
attainable there's just too little water
in the skin like it's fake it looks cged
I much prefer to have an extra you know
2 to 3% body fat I was not happy not
eating C there are certainly aspects of
Efron's intense preparation for his
Baywatch body that he will not do again
for future projects such as the use of
diuretics and some of the strict dietary
choices however going into beast mode
for workouts is something he doesn't
regret for the film he trained two times
a day five or 6 days out of the week but
that didn't seem to bother him he
explained to Men's Journal when I'm very
careful about my fitness and have a goal
in mind it keeps me motivated and
balanced I wake up earlier I don't feel
the need to be out that kills your day
your hobbies and your motivation
that same mentality came in handy for
Efron as he bulked up considerably for
the iron claw the actor told Men's
Health I enjoy pushing myself and really
laying it all out to the point where I
kind of have to do it otherwise I don't
feel like myself for his films since
Baywatch Efron has had a significantly
healthier approach to meals during
shoots in a diet focused exclusive for
Men's Health the actor said sometimes
when you're on set I give myself
permission now to sort of let up and eat
what I need to eat it's not the time or
the place to put pressure on yourself
unless you really need to be shirtless
that entire film The far less
restrictive Behavior has not only
allowed him to avoid a lot of stress but
those extra calories have also been
essential for the bulking up he needed
to do for the iron claw according to
Healthline the best way to build muscle
is to eat more food than the body needs
while carrying out intense weightlifting
based on the trailer the added calories
and Efron's Vigor for workouts were a
highly effective combination
for some time Efron's veganism helped
him achieve his lean build but
eventually he realized that the
restrictive diet was not great for his
health with that in mind the actor
transitioned to eating habits that
worked better for his body when talking
with Men's Health he said I started
intermittent fasting just after I
stopped being vegan my body wasn't
processing the vegetables in the right
way so I decided to stop it and try
something new intermittent fasting has
been really helpful with that although
it is possible to be a vegan and still
up there is no denying that adding meats
and dairy products to the diet makes the
process considerably easier according to
Healthline bodybuilders rely on
nutrient-dense foods high in protein and
healthy fats while Efron may not have
known it at the time the switch turned
out to be a great decision in
preparation for the iron claw to show
his commitment not to just bulking for
the iron claw but to using a
protein-rich diet to achieve that body
goal Efron met the interviewer for Men's
Health at a steakhouse in Thousand Oaks
California the proof that his veganism
was long over came as he ordered a wagu
steak and sides along with a Seafood
Tower to start it all off Efron then
went on to explain that the switch to
focusing on protein heavy foods made him
feel significantly less exhausted after
intense workouts but a part of him also
wished that was not the case the actor
admitted morally of course I still wish
I was vegan yet at the same time he also
seemed to have enjoyed the change based
on the way he praised the w who stake
once it arrived at the table telling his
interviewer that's why I'm not vegan
anymore for Baywatch Efron pushed his
body to the Max and paid the price
afterwards by throwing out his back
tearing his ACL breaking his wrist and
dislocating his shoulder the actor
learned his lesson the hard way that if
he was going into beast mode he must
also be just as extreme in his recovery
through his Instagram Efron shares his
extreme but successful solutions to
relax his muscle Muses like entering a
cryotherapy chamber post-workout but of
all the methods that the actor adopted
immersing himself in ice cold water gave
him the best results he told Men's
Health how ice baths had become a vital
part of his routine it's my favorite
part of the day before is when it's most
miserable and when you finally just
commit and jump in there from that point
forward you've conquered something deep
within you you do not want to get cold
that's the simplest philosophy anything
you don't want to do make it a habit
given the high level of strain he had to
put his muscles through in the
bodybuilding process for the iron claw
it sounds like the freezing cold
recovery is exactly what he needed
almost every single day during the
production of Baywatch all Efron
consumed was lean meat or fish with
sweet potatoes although the extremely
limited diet produced the desired
results he would prefer not to go that
route in the future so that was that was
the most extreme I had ever gone I think
I was in ketosis that entire film to
play Kevin von Eric in the iron claw
Efron still relied on unprocessed
nutrient-rich foods but Incorporated a
good amount of variety as well when
talking with Men's Health the actor laid
out his improved regimen in full saying
first meal of the day usually starts
with bone broth I really love bone broth
it's satisfying and it's good for your
stomach moving on to something more
substantial his next meal typically
consisted of some sort of veggies with a
really clean source of protein whether
it's chicken beef venison elk anything
Efron then ended with the most calorie
dense part of the day to provide his
muscles with the energy needed to bulk
up he told Men's Health I usually have
my highest carbohydrate meal sort of in
the evening that's usually another
really good source of meat and healthy
carbohydrate like sweet potatoes or
quinoa when an actor undergoes a major
body transformation for a role it's
always great praise if the real life
person they're supposed to play
compliments their achievement
this is especially the casee with Zack
Efron in the iron claw because Kevin von
Eric himself was thoroughly impressed
with what he has seen so far the former
wrestler told TMZ I saw a picture of the
guy he looked great I don't think I ever
looked that good as an athlete himself
Kevin is fully aware of what it took for
Efron to bulk up like he did the
wrestler added he must really be working
out hard he does have a good
body